so glad we should bring this project to
this neighborhood it's so rich in
history I grew up in a neighborhood like
this oh yeah I grew up in a neighborhood
exactly like this all right welcome to
mama sugar banks y'all ready to order
yeah can I have a chicken-fried steak
with gravy and a cola I will have the
baked beef short ribs with collard
greens and throw down some that
cornbread all right babe you know what
hold up a sec I'm also gonna have some
of the collard greens and cornbread as
well but hook a brother up with some of
them hot links all right you know what
why am I trying to front scratch all
that give me some okra and some fried
red snapper and girl you know I want
some chitlins all right y'all got ham
hocks of course well that's what I want
I want to play the ham hocks deep-fried
blackened and served on a bed of mustard
greens pig feet I want some pig feet and
four pounds of grits Oh ain't no one
else give me a little Dixie cup full of
lard all right I just remember what I
want a bowl of mosquitoes none of them
tiny ones either give me them big mother
sit down at the swamp sister could you
please hook a brother up with a rusty
bucket full of fish heads wrapped and
razor wire donkey teeth don't kitty
straight out a donkey's mouth you know
what get any animal tooth will do I want
you to stick it in some honey glaze fry
with fat back and serve it in an old tin
coffee can figured everything I said up
to this point right now bring me some
dandelion greens a cow hip and a dog
face wrap that whole mess in an old
Ebony magazine and serve it to me in a
shoebox okay I want a platter of stork
ankles an old cellar door a possum spine
and a human foot
you want a human foot mm-hmm I got just
one question for y'all
you want gravy on that cellar door oh
definitely oh yeah yeah you gotta put
gravy on it yes I saw the door without
gravy it's not food that's really
you